venez là non jérôme commandeur mettez
vos habitudes et là vous jouez avec nous
chez vous bien sur ces questions pour un
barbecue on joue avec julien lepers
bon je découvre en même temps 1 1 à oui
oui oui oui oui oui oui bienvenue
bienvenue dans questions pour un
champion ils sont venus pour ce
questions pour un champion spécial
barbecue aux questions ah oui à la
question pour un barbecue très beau film
qui sort demain avec l'immense jérôme
commandeur c'est bien les crises ah oui
les mots ce que l'acteur seriez vous
êtes passionné de barbecue vous à jouer
contre ce fait il se fait se congratule
ah oui je me suis trop cadeaux à gagner
jingle la caméra et en même temps je me
méfie chaumeton sur les courses alors
l'encyclopédie a gagné écoutez bien ce
cas doit gagner l'encyclopédie des
boules de l'aisne dans le nombril de
l'homme à travers les siècles
un beau cadeau avant un couteau après
soir en famille aux éditions label
michaud et la belle-mère
bonjour tout de suite les thèmes
proposés à cirer que j'ai démarré par
séries pardon se fait alors à vous de
choisir nous avons la chipolata chez les
mayas le rôle de la lune fait écouter
bien sûr le rôle de la lune feu dans le
film camping 2 oui la sauce béarnaise
sous la vème république c'est pas facile
et jean-michel merguez sa vie son oeuvre
jean-michel merguez on aime les jeux de
mots et le barbecue en général et sinon
tintin à prendre s'assurer dans la mer
alors je prends le barbecue en général
parce qu'ici on est dans la merde c'est
parfait rouste un bon choix pour le
diable c'est parti attention pas d'un 10
pour vous qui êtes chez vous je suis une
saucisse longues et fines d'environ 2 cm
de diamètre on appelle aussi godiveau je
suis généralement à base de chair à
saucisse de porc moyennement h et en
beauce et d'un noyau de boyau naturel
ment l'assaisonnement peu contient
vraiment du thym ou de la sauge de
muscade je suis je suis à la chipolata
raoui
oui je viens je suis en santé en 90 et
classées d'intérêt du top 50 est appâtée
par framboise et des muscles et le titre
comporte des phrases cultes tels que
tant qu'il ya de la bresse c'est pas
fini ou encore yann à l'ail ou las vegas
party
et
là
la caisse partie j'écris pour herbert
léonard mais j'aurais pu l'écrire
une fine tige en métal ou en bois sur
laquelle sont invités des morceaux de
boeuf porc volailles canard poisson de
fruits de mer des saynètes cuit à la
broche salaires au dessus des braises
dessus des barbecues je suis je suis
je voudrais remercier inamicale départ
touffeur de la poste de mitrailleur